[Music]  we all know sunscreen is important this  time of year but a report finds many of  the products on store shelves don't  offer adequate protection the  environmental working group evaluated  more than 1800 different products and  found just 25 percent met the group's  standards  how effective they are at providing  adequate broad spectrum protection and  then we look at the inactive ingredients  to make sure  that those also aren't linked to  health harms  now researching sunscreen chemicals and  new rules are expected in the fall but  ewg is urging consumers to switch to  mineral products now and be aware some  sunscreens say on the front label that  they're mineral based but every  sunscreen lists its active ingredients  on the back your best bet look for zinc  oxide titanium dioxide or both the  minerals reflect uv rays and are not  absorbed into the skin the group says  avoid sunscreens with the chemical  oxybenzone and that absorbs easily and  is linked to health concerns